all right darn it oh yes
where'd you grow up reefer Mercer I was
born in Oakland California but I've been
here in Los Angeles ever since I was 2
years oh okay and tell me about your
family you grew up with both your
parents um until I was 10 years old at
the time when I was 10 I was molested by
my father first time I had sex I had got
pregnant so I came downtown to the st.
Ann's maternity home
over in the Alvarado area I stayed there
I was 10
you're pregnant yes first time I had sex
I got pregnant nurse by my dad I stayed
there for about six months and then whoa
about six weeks and then I agreed to
have an abortion to go home back home at
the time we were living in Compton
California
I stayed at home with maybe for about a
year then I started running away from
home I was in and out of McClaren Hall
different foster homes I was in like
1415 foster homes
the sexual abuse with your dad continued
yes I only had sexual with sex with my
father until I was what 19 20 years old
I never had another man but I had my
daughter at 16 which is also my little
sister I had her by my father I have two
children now when I was 21 I had another
well seven years later I had another
child a boy
I've been downtown ever since 1984 the
beginning of 84 like the first of the
year when I first moved down here I
moved into where the st. mark says the
611 the woman and children's shelter
I've been downtown
ever since I was homeless 20 years down
here I just got my housing about maybe
three years ago tournament housing I was
a transit down here on the street in the
tents and you know I've lived in every
last one of these hotels downtown area I
don't have a really bad criminal
background I have a couple of drug sales
you know so but let's back up to your
parents so did your dad ever do any
prison time for what he didn't know my
mother kept him so I mean you know it
was just just something that you know
she chose to say it was my fault so
something about it was my fault so
I mean yeah I was warm leash I was fast
and I enticed them or whatever I mean
between that and her trying to refuse
that it was even happening at all she
knew what was happening because she knew
I was pregnant so I I had my baby I went
back home with my mom and I stayed there
for about like six months we were living
in Carson there I you know had both of
my kids with me too my daughter was like
maybe 10 til 84 when I had my son and in
83 I came downtown I applied for GR I
came downtown they put me at the 611 and
I've been downtown ever since so your
kids are raised by you um
they were raised by me my daughter
stayed with me until she was 10 then she
you know stay with my mom my son was
raised by my boyfriend I only had a one
boyfriend all through school and so my
son was raised by him that's my phone so
so your daughter went with your mom was
your dad still in the picture well he
was still alive you know him and my mom
weren't together but yeah she she went
with my mom it was I mean it was like
preferable to her going into foster care
I have been in foster care so I didn't
want her to go in foster care
my mom I gave them gave her to my mom
too
you know she wanted my daughter and you
were on the streets and she yeah she
didn't want my my baby so I was in the
streets of Long Beach for a while and
then I came downtown like on a fluke
with one a friend of mine came down to
apply for gr and I applied there for
only time I've ever
been on gr so you have a son as well I
have a son as well he's 35 36 actually
he'll be 36 next month so you raised him
no he was raised when he was three well
I had them both til she was ten and he
was three that's when I came downtown
and when I came down to my son was
raised by one of my boyfriend's he you
know was there when my son was born so
it was a he no he wasn't the father
that's one of the problems that happens
my son right now because my son is mixed
with Mexican and black so it's a great
big difference but he was my boyfriend
for all the time I was in junior high
school my first boyfriend other than my
dad
so he raised my son he came to the
County Building
he got my son and he raised him until he
was grown
I recently been back in my son's life
maybe about a year and a half and he
came down he found me actually right
before he had his son right when he had
his son his son is seven so he's been
back in my life like seven years my son
my daughter she she lives in Antelope
Valley she just recently found out
within the last seven years about me and
her having the same father you know she
really didn't know she she had
you know thoughts about it but she
didn't really know the truth yeah like I
said I've been a transit down here for
laughs going on 30 years
I just recently acquired Parliament
housing I live in the Alexander hotel
right now do you use any of the drugs on
the street here oh yeah I was an addict
I was a crack addict you know the last
20 years I started using crack when I
was about maybe when my son after my son
was born and basically I've been a crack
at it you know I've been in recovery for
the last year trying to get my life
together
I have relapse problems but what'd he do
for money there I I finally have an
income after 20 years of being here with
no income at all I'm on disability SSI
disability so until you got that how are
you supporting yourself that's how I
support myself no but before that before
that I crack sales I sold enough dope I
was a worker
I sold enough dope to pay them you know
by me I outfit every day you know II you
know pay my rent because I lived in all
these hotels before they turned their
sorrow I was paying by the day 2030
I mean $50 $60 a day so I made enough
money you know I have five sales cases
narrowing of the cases that I have are
me having my own sack I was just I never
was a baller I just was a worker
I still have problems every now and then
with my you know with my addiction
finding something to replace the
addiction is a problem
do you still have contact with your
family my two children I'm the only one
left of my family it's me and my two
kids yes I still have contact with them
my son he was in prison he did seven
years for abuse he has problems with
women mostly it's my fault because I was
the crack head that he heard about all
this life he was just like your mom
she's a crackhead on Skid Row that's all
he ever heard all his life so he has
mental problems
you know I guess some sanity runs in our
family
but yeah dysfunction oh yeah that's
common story down here do you think if
your childhood had been different that
your life might have led led you down a
different path I'm pretty sure yeah I'm
pretty sure what did what do you would
you say your parents my mom was a
groupie you know she was she was a
definition of a groupie you know up
north she was part of the pastor family
she they were groupies you know my
auntie es son by Johnny Guitar Watson
you know the musical the music field you
know she was uh she was a groupie yeah
yeah they drop pills and go to concerts
and you know me and my cousin they had
to take us with him so you know we grew
up together
she you know my dad he was security he
worked at the Federal Reserve Bank of
San Francisco right here on Olympic and
grand for 35 years he retired from there
he's dead now but if he was alive I mean
basically all of my relationships are
dysfunctional
based on my dysfunctional beginning you
know I was married for five years
I'm just recently divorced all of my
relationships are dysfunctional based on
it so yes I believe if my beginning for
different I would have had a different
know some different role models a
different yeah a little more I was you
know if everything that was right was
wrong and everything that was wrong
was right I mean that's the way it is
always feeling with me you know starting
with my dad I mean all of the tears for
healing all of the things you know me
knowing it wasn't my father I was a
child you know a molestation and all of
that it really didn't pan out with me
because my I was in love with my father
my father did was my everything he did
everything for me you know that was the
only thing that was long and so you know
it made my all my relationships are
dysfunctional because of that you know I
believe if I'm not getting paid or
whatever for it so that made me have a
dysfunctional marriage you know I had
issues because of that yeah you know
basically that's where I'm an and I'm
still downtown
all right don't it well thank you so
much for talk to me and sharing your
story good luck with everything
you